the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives shahada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your scale
[Music]
how are you guys doing it's been a long
time since I've addressed you from this
very prestigious location next to these
two champs on my left there two failures
abject failures here that you can't see
and a
good but I recently came across a
video um Joe Rogan was having a
conversation with taka Carlson and two
figures who are no doubt big figures in
the conservative world and also in
American culture generally they were
talking about God and they were talking
about AI I found it interesting let's
take a look at this and come back and
respond in kind and better versions of
itself where does that go that goes to a
god it literally create un what kind of
God so like I I think of it this way so
the first stage of the Industrial
Revolution consisted of people building
machine that were stronger than the
human body right right so the steam
powered Loom sure the back combustion
engine combustion engine they replace
they replace muscles right right so
that's what the machine does it it
becomes stronger than the human body the
second stage which we in the middle of
consists of creating machines that are
more powerful than the human
mind that's what Computing is and I
would say AI or super Computing it's
just
that exponentially uh
but that doesn't make it a God in the
sense that the machine however powerful
it is any more than a backhoe is a God
because it can dig a trench faster than
100 men it it's still something that
people created yes it's an interesting
video I think it's very interesting
because I think they were coming from
different perspectives different
paradigms Joe Rogan is an atheist or an
agnos from my understanding I might be
wrong about that maybe he's changed his
views and takal said I think may be a
Christian so this is probably where the
disagreement if we want to call it that
because really they weren't overtly
disagreeing although in wording they
were may be as a result of um a God is
different to God right with a capital G
because God with a capital G refers to
what we would consider to be the creator
of the universe you see the maintainer
of the universe the sustainer of the
universe the one with valtion and will
and power and knowledge this is usually
the definition of a god which most
people accept having said this um on the
issue of AI the reason why AI cannot be
even less than a
God and be conscious is because it
always requires an inputter this is the
reality of the situation as much as AI
develops listen carefully to this please
yes as much as AI develops there's
always going to be an inputter that is
required it's never going to have a
first person subjective experience it's
never going to have Consciousness and
Consciousness is really defined as a
inner personal subjective State a
computer or a machine will never feel
anything in the same way as a human
being or even an animal would be
considered to be able to feel something
anger
love it will never do so and there are
many experiments that have been done and
discussions that have been had in the
world of philosophy under the banner of
what is referred to as the hard problem
of Consciousness which people find hard
in the first place to Define that one
can refer to if they want more
information about this but one of the
interesting things is referred to as the
Chinese room experiment and once again I
don't have time to speak to you about or
spell out how that looks but the point
is look computers and software are
essentially loops and conditionals
that's what they are loops and
conditionals and they always require an
inputter they will never feel anything
they'll never have first person
subjective experience they'll never
graduate to the level of a human being
or an animal and this is very
interesting because the Quran the of
course we as Muslims believe that this
is the word of God this is the
communication and the Revelation from
God Mighty to human beings on this
planet Earth for the guidance of human
beings States the following it says in
the that all of those who you worship
aside from God will not be able to
create even a fly and even if you come
together and if you think about this the
parable of the fly the example of the
fly the similitude of The Fly
the similitude of the fly the fly is a
living
creature something with life something
which can be considered or inferred to
have firsters subjective
experience AI can never reach that level
the Quran is already telling us this it
will never reach that level now that's
not to say that AI like Tako Carlson was
alluding here will not reach very high
levels and chat GPT and all those kind
of things and robots and people have
this kind of thing and cars self-driving
cars maybe self-driving planes whatever
it may be but there are always going to
be limits to that which human being
creates and the first and final limit is
that human being will always have to
create from a material that was already
put in place by God and
moreover that anything that is done by
human will be credited or God will be
given the credit for that because he's
the ultimate
responsible the ultimately responsible
one for all things anyone other than him
does being the ultimate one having said
this I hope that Joe Rogan realizes the
Preposterous nature of believing that
there is not a
foundational entity that brought rise to
all that exists and that which all that
exists depends upon and I hope that taka
cson also realizes that the same
argument that he applied to AI can be
applied to his idea of Jesus as being
God the same limitations that AI have to
being God are the same that anything
else would have that's why Islam is the
religion of truth I invite you both to
it taka and Joe
hey you are you wasting your time on
social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a Masid a DA Center
establishing a Masjid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even more